ronnie jackson tweets quote  sad to see that despite vaccines  boosters multiple masks and social  distancing fouchy has contracted covid i  hope you get well  very soon exclamation point i mean a  more more sarcastic well wishes are hard  to imagine you'll need to be in tip-top  shape when the republican majority takes  congress lots of testifying while under  investigation  next year  it's great to see  that a fellow doctor i mean guys think  think about how disgusting this ronnie  jackson guy is a fellow doctor oh i hope  you're gonna need to be in tip-top shape  i hope you get well soon because you're  going to be under investigation when we  take over next year